Good morning Hank, it's Wednesday. I have
a zit so big that when I get close to the
camcorder, my camcorder believes that my zit
is a face. I mean frankly Hank, this zit is
so big that I've begun to wonder whether it's
going to develop self consciousness and because
of that I've been thinking about conjoined
twins.
So Hank, I thought I would one up your top
five video from Monday and give you top six
pairs of conjoined twins in history, which
is actually, not to brag or anything, kind
of a top twelve.
Number six, the Biddenden Maids. Mary and
Eliza Chulkhurst were conjoined twins who
left five plots of land when they died to
benefit the poor of their town Biddenden.
And for the last five hundred years, continuing
up to today, every Easter there's lots of
stuff for the poor people in this town thanks
to Mary and Eliza. In addition to like bread
and cheese and stuff, pensioners and widows
also get Biddenden Cakes which are these like
massively disgusting biscuits printed with
conjoined twins on them. Like one 19th century
historian referred to them as "not by any
means tempting". Anyway Hank, let that be
a lesson to you, if you leave your money to
charity they will print your face on disgusting
biscuits forever but if you leave your money
to your brother, he will spend it.
Number five, Giacomo and Giovanni Tocci. Giacomo
and Giovanni were conjoined twins with two
heads, four arms and two legs and like a lot
of conjoined twins, they spent pretty much
their entire childhood on the freak show circuit.
In fact, the Tocci twins spent like five years
touring America during which time Mark Twain
heard about them, which inspired him to write
"Those Extraordinary Twins" and also inspired
indirectly the great novel "Pudd'nhead Wilson".
So basically without the Tocci twins, Mark
Twain is a lesser novelist. See and people
say that the history of conjoined twindom
is not interesting. Stop looking at my zit!
Number four, Lori and George Schappell who
are still living and despite sharing 30% of
their brain matter, have very different lives.
Lori works part time at a hospital laundry.
George is a professional country singer. By
the way, they are both female - all conjoined
twins are identical. Its like an autonomous
region of John Green.
Number three, Jodie and Marie - not their
real names. So in 2000, conjoined twins are
born in the United Kingdom - Jodie and Mary.
Jodie was the stronger of the two twins - her
heart basically pumped for Mary's blood system.
Mary was a separate person, with a separate
brain but she couldn't survive without Jodie.
Doctors determined that both twins would inevitably
die unless they were separated but if they
were separated Mary would die immediately.
Mary and Jodie's parents didn't want them
to be separated but a court ordered the procedure.
As expected, Mary died, Jodie survived and,
in fact, is still alive today. And the case
raised all kinds of questions about personhood
and medical ethics, a discussion that I'm
sure will continue in the comments.
Number two, Chang and Eng, the stars of this
great book "God's Fool". Chang and Eng were
the original Siamese twins, they had a crazy
life that started in Thailand and took them
all around the world. They eventually brought
a tobacco plantation in North Carolina, married
sisters and had 21 kids between the two of
them. Like a lot of the non-separated conjoined
twins we're talking about, they had a fascinating
and very rich life, that in some ways was
probably better than it would have been if
they had been born singletons. Which, by the
way Hank, is the word for people who aren't
conjoined like, you know, us and most people.
This takes me to my favourite conjoined twins
of all time, Millie and Christine McKoy, who
were known as "the two-headed Nightingale".
Millie and Christine were born into slavery
in 1851, sold repeatedly, taken away from
their mother, eventually kidnapped by a guy
who toured them around the world while beating
them. They were eventually taken back by one
of their owners and reunited with their biological
mother and the slave owner and his wife taught
Millie and Christine how to speak five languages
and how to sing in perfect harmony, but also
owned them as property and took all their
money. But then when they were 13, the Emancipation
Proclamation, freed them and they went on
to work sideshows with Barnum and Bailey and
made a tonne of money. Certainly, Millie and
Christine were exploited throughout their
lives, but its hard to say their lives would
be better if they had been separated at birth.
And that's really what fascinates me about
conjoined twins. We're so obsessed with the
idea that unusual anatomies need to be made
normal, that we forget that unusual anatomies
can have many advantages. That's not to say
that conjoinedness is entirely desirable,
just that the reality of conjoinedness, like
most realities, resists simplicity.
Lastly Nerdfighters, as I'm sure you are aware,
there have been devastating floods in Queensland,
Australia. There is a link in the doobleydoo
to help people who have been affected by those
floods. Don't Forget To be Awesome. Hank,
I will see you on Friday.